la cncl vote de bouygues tf attribue au
numéro un du bâtiment et à ses
partenaires scènes d'émeute et nuit
dernière à santiago pendant une messe de
jean paul 2 il y à un morts et 600
blessés
le congrès du parti socialiste de lille
lionel jospin en quête de sa direction
et puis ce samedi 4 avril encore un jour
de détention pour les otages français au
liban
marcel fontaine et marcel carton jean
paul kauffmann et jean louis normandin
n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonsoir le mieux-disant
s'appelle francis bouygues c'est ce qu'a
décidé sans attendre la commission
nationale de la communication et des
libertés en lui attribue aujourd'hui 50%
du capital de tf1 aux dépens du groupe
hachette pourtant donné grand favori
c'est l'information qui domine ce samedi
c'est un peu une surprise que nous
allons développer abondamment
aujourd'hui mais tout de suite voici la
réaction de francis bouygues
c'était quelques minutes après l'annoncé
officielle maryse manu philippe petter
l'attend dette ou bas de chez lui ce
pouvoir concurrents alors quelle est
votre réaction à chaud quoi je suis je
suis heureux je suis très satisfait
quand avez vous appris et qu'ils
voulaient appris j'ai appris ça à deux
heures j'étais au restaurant est ce que
vous êtes surpris
bah oui et non j'aime bien les grands
challenges
j'aime bien gagner et je voudrais avant
j'ai toujours pensé que j'avais une
bonne chance
est-ce que vous pensez que les pressions
que vous avez exercé un petit peu sur la
cncl en essayant de disqualifier votre
partenaire ont joué non ça c'est un
filet de sécurité
alors comme on faisait du grand trapèze
c'était très difficile c'était une
opération très très compliqué bon bah
achète n'avait pas ne jouais pas de
manière régulière donc on a pris
quelques précautions
mais il s'avère aujourd'hui que ces
précautions ont été tout à fait inutile
et d'ailleurs on s'est arrangé pour
qu'elle soit inutile et on s'est arrangé
pour que notre dossier soit un vrai
dossier de professionnels mais pas l'air
de sauter de joie ou alors est ce que
votre joie est rentré non non non les
parents prêts du tout ma joie elle est
totale mais vous savez quand je réussir
quelque chose
un grand challenge dans la ville en ait
réussi un assez grand nombre
je pense toujours à ce qui va se passer
demain est là pour tf1 ce qui va compter
il ya beaucoup de travail à faire la
seule chose que nous allons faire c'est
réfléchir voilà les secrets des grandes
manoeuvres et puis cette image
symbolique que vous allez voir c'était
dans l'après midi
c'est francis bouygues qui arrivait à
tf1 rue cognacq-jay monsieur bouygues et
qui étaient cueillis vous voir par le
président c'est là que le président
hervé bourges que celui qui venait donc
faire en quelque sorte le tour du
propriétaire
de sa nouvelle entreprise voilà hervé
bourges en compagnie de francis briest
c'était dans l'après midi à l'entrée de
la rue cognacq-jay alors tf1 attribué à
bouygues et à ses partenaires cela veut
dire que l'équipe menée par le numéro un
du bâtiment disposera de 50 % du capital
de la société de télévision privatiser
les 50% restants seront partagés entre
les salariés et le public
alors aujourd'hui qui possède quoi de
tf1 la réponse de christophe martet avec
3 milliards de francs le nouveau patron
de tf1 n'a que la moitié de la une
le personnel de la chaîne et le public
pourront en effet devenir actionnaire et
acquérir les trois milliards restants
francis bouygues
le leader mondial du bâtiment disposera
quant à lui de 25% du capital de tf1
privatisé il s'est entouré d'une équipe
de patrons de presse et d'hommes
d'affaires pour son tour de table
robert maxwell tout d'abord propriétaire
d'un empire de presse et d'édition
britannique hylas 1 10e du gâteau le
groupe gmf fnac et le troisième
actionnaire avec 3% du capital
autre tête d'affiche bernard tapie
patron de 45 entreprises dont la vie
claire et les piles vander antoine de
clermont tonnerre des éditions mondiales
le numéro deux français de la presse
magazine et évelyne provost pdg de marie
claire
les groupes financiers comme la banque
indosuez où le crédit lyonnais sont
également actionnaires
enfin bouygues a laissé 0,5 pour cent du
capital à la presse écrite et aux
maisons d'édition une double surprise
que ce choix de la cncl d'abord parce
qu'on donnait achète grands favoris
comme qu'il faut demeurer prudent la ses
pronostics mais aussi parce que les 13
membres de la commission avaient en
principe jusqu'au 10 avril pour se faire
une religion alors pourquoi si vite et
pourquoi bouygues
voici ce qu'a pu savoir aujourd'hui gaël
monk ils sont arrivés à 10h au 56 au
siège de la commission
ils ont fini de voter vers 13h45
pourquoi une décision si rapide parce
que les 13 membres de la commission hier
soir à la fin des auditions avaient déjà
fait leur choix qu'ils n'avaient plus
besoin de complément d'information et
qu'ils ne se sentaient pas l' envie de
faire durer le suspense plus longtemps
leur choix à une majorité d'au moins
huit voix francis bouygues
sa formidable volonté de gagner qu'ils
ont physiquement ressenti à chacune de
leurs rencontres
bouille et son groupe tout à fait à
l'aise et détendu
parce que les auditions n'était qu'une
répétition d'un échange qui avait déjà
eu lieu
les membres avaient eu le loisir dans
les jours précédant d'étudier tous les
points du dossier
ils n'attendaient qu'une confirmation
francis bouygues le roi du béton avait
tout répéter minutieusement ficelé avec
une extrême rigueur son projet pour
faire la preuve que sur le mieux disant
culturel
il n'avait de leçon à recevoir de
personne le dossier le voici
il contient tous les détails y compris
la grille de programme complète et
détaillée mais le choix s'est sans doute
fait parce que bouygues s'est posée
comme un repreneur un actionnaire
majoritaire aux reins solides en matière
de programme il s'engage bien au delà du
cahier des charges en matière
d'information il promet l'autonomie de
la rédaction lors des auditions du
groupe hachette les questions opposés
sur les risques de concentration
excessive
c'est un point le dossier présenté
encore des imprécisions avant les
auditions
le groupe se proposait d'être opérateur
et peut-être jean luc lagardère at il
péché par orgueil sur la culture ils
croyaient n'avoir pas de leçons à
recevoir les membres de la commission
ont tranché ce rachat de tf1 s'inscrit
dans la stratégie de diversification
engagée il ya plusieurs années
maintenant par le groupe de francis
bouygues d'une société dont pourtant le
secteur travaux publics et bâtiments
fournit le nerf de la guerre jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
weeks étaient essentiellement des
chantiers de première importance mais
pas seulement cela jean-pierre motivé
francis bouygues visitant l'un de ses
chantiers au koweït en 1982 sa
profession bâtisseurs sa spécialité
décroché de fabuleux contrat le pont de
boubiyan mais aussi l'université de ryad
où le stade de téhéran et en france les
chantiers prestigieux comme le parc des
princes le forum des halles et bientôt
le tunnel sous la manche un groupe qui
pèse 46 milliards de francs et qui a su
prévoir la fin des grands contrats
francis bouygues à une parade ils
rachètent des entreprises
c'est comme la chasse dit il on tire sur
le gibier qui se présentent en 85
reprises des piles vont der mazda en
participation avec bernard tapie
weeds s'intéressent même à la
distribution de luxe et rachète le
magasin des trois quartiers mais il lui
arrive aussi de manquer sa cible
il rate de peu framatome et le nucléaire
en 1985 il rate aussi les assurances
trous et il continue de bétonner le
secteur des travaux publics
il en est le numéro un mondial depuis le
rachat d'un autre bâtisseurs français la
screg est une prise de participation
dans spie batignolles ses participations
francis bouygues vient tout juste de la
revendre du coup son trésor de guerre
est évaluée aujourd'hui à 3 milliards de
franck et lorsque francis bouygues et
ses partenaires remporte tf1 on est en
droit de se demander ce qu'en pense le
personnel de la chaîne alors pour le
savoir dès l'annoncé de la décision de
la cncl ice poirier et armés de sel se
sont promenés dans les couloirs de
cognac jay comme nous disant king beh
oui mais pas bouygues patrice drevet du
mini journal a beau chercher il n'a pas
le numéro de téléphone de francs 6 oui
pourtant il est plutôt rassuré par le
choix de la cncl comme la plupart des
journalistes et des techniciens de tf1
au bik s'est toujours présenté comme un
repreneur et non pas comme un opérateur
et a toujours dit vouloir faire
confiance aux gens qui ont fait le
succès tf1
donc ça c'est un bon point pour la
maison deuxième point il a une grosse
surface financière des ambitions
européennes ce qui peut donner beaucoup
dynamisme la maison troisième point qui
me tient à coeur c'est que il a fait la
première est engagé
les 35 pigistes qui ont travaillé depuis
longtemps avec nous des jeunes
journalistes que mais qui n'était pas
statutaire effet très content pour eux
parce qu'ils ont fait beaucoup pour tfc
non les changements plus journal
continue pas de temps à perdre
on prépare le vainqueur de ce soir
présentation du groupe bouygues ses
objectifs en matière de communication et
surtout on espère francis vont en direct
sur le plateau confiant donc et pourtant
vigilant demanderont une information
indépendante objective pluraliste que la
part soit faite au grand reportage au
traitement des grands événements de ce
monde et de la société française
les sociétés autre que française francis
bouygues s'est engagé solennellement
devant la cncl il ne veut pas casser la
une
ils veulent à gérer a tf1 on attend tout
simplement qu'il tienne ses promesses
voilà et puis de réactions font défaut
ce soir celle de vachette le candidat
malheureux dans cette affaire mais on
préfère semble-t-il garder le silence ce
soir dans l'entourage de jean luc
lagardère et de ses associés aucun
commentaire non plus de la haute
autorité
plutôt de la cncl dont les membres joint
au téléphone se refuse à toute
déclaration
quelques réactions enfin du côté des
hommes politique le rpr dans la majorité
par exemple qui espère que l'équipe
conduite par bouygues fera preuve
d'impartialité de dynamisme et
d'imagination pour françois léotard le
miz de la communication mission
accomplie pour françois d'aubert et qui
est pro barriste la privatisation d'edf
prendre un bon départ et puis à gauche
pour le parti socialiste jack lang
l'ancien ministre de la culture estime
que les socialistes eux jugeront sur
pièce enfin lionel jospin le premier
secrétaire du ps qui est à lille
dedic que l'idée des socialistes de
rendre tf1 au service public reste
aujourd'hui encore valable voilà donc
pour ces réactions havre ac d'autres
réactions plus complète sans doute dans
le tout dernier journal c'est en tout
cas ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
cette reprise officielle de 50% tf1 par
francis bouygues et par ses partenaires
la suite de l'actualité maintenant c'est
d'abord le voyage de jean paul ii au
chili avec un chiffre terrible hein
morts et 600 blessés hier soir des
affrontements très très dur entre la
police et des manifestants à quelques
dizaines de mètres seulement de
l'endroit où le pape célébrait la messe
dans un billet spéciaux bernard benyamin
et j'aurais ont assisté aux
affrontements
voici leurs témoignages
16h hier nous sommes au parco higgins en
place entre de santiago l'atmosphère est
extrêmement tendue la foule se presse
contre les grilles de protection
menaçant à tout moment de les renverser
carabiniers et membres de la sécurité
papale et c'est de contenir la poussée
de milliers de personnes pendant que des
enfants sont sauvés d'extrême justesse
de l'étouffement
avec une heure de retard dans le bruit
et la poussière
jean paul ii arrive enfin pour commencer
la cérémonie de béatification de soeur
thérèse des andes
c'est à ce moment là que le premier feu
fait son apparition au milieu de la
foule
simultanément plusieurs groupes de
jeunes armés de bâtons se dirige vers la
tribune officielle
pas de doute on va vers l'affrontement
entre temps la cérémonie a commencé
il s'agit de donner aux chiliens la
première sainte de son histoire
16h30 il attaque d'abord avec des
pierres prenant pour cible les
journalistes et les carabiniers
très vite les grilles de protection vont
voler en éclats dès lors la panique va
être général et le parc va se
transformer en champ de bataille
moi
il y aura 600 blessés à la fin de la
journée sur le terrain certains évêques
essaient de s'interposer appelant au
calme en vain pendant ce temps jean paul
2 n'a pas un regard ni un mot pour ce
qui se passe à 100 mètres de lui
la scène va alors glissé vers le
surréalisme les voitures à eau des
carabiniers ont chargé les manifestants
au son des cantiques
la santé
la bande à gillot
lorsque nous parvenons enfin décent dans
le parc une ronde s'est formé autour
d'un corps afin de le protéger
peine perdue la voiture à eau charges
tout le monde
le corse est celui d'une journaliste
chilienne photographe touché par deux
balles venus d'on ne sait où elle est
grièvement blessée à l'épaule
une nouvelle fois la voiture à eau
arrive une nouvelle fois nous tentons de
protéger la journaliste blessée une
nouvelle fois nous n'y arriverons pas
pendant ce temps la cérémonie se termine
le chili vient d'avoir officiellement sa
première 5 ce matin en tout cas le
gouvernement chilien publié un
communiqué accusant formellement les
jeunesses communistes d'être à l'origine
de ces incidents les jeunesses
communistes ont immédiatement rejeté
l'accusation affirmant que les
manifestants d'hier aidée des bandes de
jeunes fasciste qui avait provoqué ces
incidents afin de justifier par avance
une terrible répression
quoi qu'il en soit jamais visite papale
n'aura provoqué une telle violence
voilà et ce soir le pape a quitté
santiago il est arrivé à punta arenas au
sud du pays au sud du chili
la reprise de tf1 par francis bouygues a
bien sûr là encore nourri les
discussions hors tribunaux congrès du
parti socialiste de lille pourtant
l'essentiel n'était pas là pour ce
dernier jour vraiment politique du
congrès aujourd'hui il était d'abord
question de la direction du parti et de
la synthèse attendu nous retrouvons nos
envoyés spéciaux se sont jean-michel
mercurol et jean vila ce soir si ce
n'était l'hommage de laurent fabius à
françois mitterrand pour son effort de
20 ans cette deuxième journée à lille
n'aurait guère réveiller le congrès
commencé dans l'unité célébrée dans la
synthèse
il finit dans l'unanimité mis à part le
sursaut d'un jean poperen rétrogradé de
son poste de numéro 2 pour mésentente
avec lionel jospin
le premier secrétaire va disposer
désormais d'une direction resserrée ou
entre des hommes d'expérience qui pour
la plupart ont assumé le pouvoir
voilà maintenant le parti tout entier
tendu vers la victoire en 88 cents qui
les tuent a désigné deux candidats même
si depuis hier les deux possibles
s'appelle dans l'ordre françois
mitterrand et michel rocard
tous les orateurs ont sacrifié au rite
du genre appel à la mobilisation
affirmation de la générosité et de
l'humanisme de la gauche dénonciation de
la droite et de l'adversaire principal
vraiment barre je n'ai juste pas ce sera
peut exprimer jusque là ils se réservent
pour demain devant les vingt mille
militants attendus
tous et qu'outreau alors le message venu
de l'elysée et la grand messe sera
achevée la réponse de moscou aux
expulsions de diplomates soviétiques qui
était en poste à paris après l' affaire
d'espionnage autour d'ariane
moscou vient de décider de l'expulser
six français s'ils font c'est qu'ils
sont donc expulsé de moscou 3 dans un
premier temps il s'agit de deux membres
de l'ambassade de france et des
représentants d'une société française
et puis par la suite trois autres
français seront à nouveau expulsés donc
six diplomates français expulsé
vous savez que la france avait décidé
d'expulser trois diplomates soviétiques
après cette affaire d'espionnage des
ballons par milliers dans le ciel de
paris et d'ailleurs le coup d'envoi
d'une campagne nationale au profit des
grands accidentés de la vie
l'exemple venait de haut puisque le
président de la république et le
gouvernement avait amorcé le mouv
bernard pradines haut face aux malheurs
que constitue un handicap physique
il faut une formidable volonté pour
renaître à la vie ani le président
mitterrand et le chef de l'état a
surtout souligné l'effort de solidarité
indispensable dans tous ces domaines
c'est un devoir qu'il faut rappeler sans
cesse a répété le président de la
république au micro de noël mamère
puisqu'il s'agit d'abord de dominer sa
propre vie gay dans quelles
circonstances où son caractère son
courage sa volonté de surmonter sa
volonté de faire comme les autres
peut-être de faire comme avant en dépit
de la difficulté et je crois aussi que
ceux qui agissent ainsi ont le sentiment
d'avoir un devoir social ce qui m'a tant
d'autres qui ne peuvent en arriver là
presse ils veulent donner l'exemple
dans l'après midi c'est au jardin des
tuileries que monsieur alain juppé au
nom de monsieur chirac a participé au
lancement de cette campagne nationale en
faveur des grands accidentés de la vie
photo de famille de rigueur à l'hôtel
matignon où jacques chirac jacques
chirac recevait à déjeuner les rugbymen
du quinze de france les hommes de
dubroca qui on vous le savez remporté
cette année un quatrième grand chelem
c'était la raison de cette réunion où on
a beaucoup parlé du ballon ovale alors
même que se jouait les deux derniers
matches du tournoi des cinq nations
car si la france a bien gagné il restait
encore deux rencontres sachez donc que
l'irlande l'a emporté sur le pays de
galles et que l'écho s'est incliné
devant l'angleterre ce qui donne le
classement suivant pour ce tournoi 87
premiers la france 2e ex-aequo l'irlande
et l'ecosse quatrième le pays de galles
est cinquième et dernier l'anglais un
magnifique contrat je vous le disais
hier soir pour airbus industrie avec le
projet d'achat de la compagnie
américaine northwest pour 30 appareils
de la nouvelle génération ce que l'on
appelle les a330 et les a340
c'est un tournant capital en tout cas
pour le consortium qui n'a pas encore
commencé la fabrication de ses avions
explications de laurent bousses le voilà
c'est lui l'a340 il ne volera pas avant
trois ou quatre ans la décision
officielle de le construire n'est pas
encore prise et pourtant on parle déjà
beaucoup beaucoup de lui avec ses quatre
réacteurs son rayon d'action de 14,8 km
et ses 328 passagers
il sera le premier gros porteurs long
courriers d'airbus industrie chez boeing
on le voit arriver avec suspicion mais
en europe on fonde de gros espoirs sur
lui puisque avec son frère jumeau l'a330
ils sont la prochaine génération
d'avions du consortium européen comme
l'a320 il s'attaque allègrement au
marché américain et la commande passée
hier par northwest airlines porte à six
le nombre de compagnies qui ont
officiellement décidé d'en acheter
cette annonce va certainement accélérer
leur processus de lancement et comme une
bonne nouvelle ne vient jamais seule le
jour même une autre firme américaine
l'international les inco signaient un
protocole d'accord pour l'acquisition de
trois a330 et deux trois a320 décidément
depuis quelques mois
l'amérique réussit bien aux avions
européens un autre gros porteur mais
destiné à affronter les vagues seule
fois le plus gros paquebot de croisière
du monde vient d'être mise à l'eau dans
les chantiers alstom de saint nazaire
souverains des mères c'est ainsi qu'il
s'appelle armé par une compagnie
norvégienne pourra emporter deux mille
six cents passagers 23 décembre prochain
il est donc le plus gros ou du monde et
ses deux premiers voyages affiche déjà
complet
malgré le prix du billet qui est de
l'ordre de 9000
alors que pour la mise à l'eau de ce
souverain des mères qui est donc
aujourd'hui le plus gros paquebot et
quittez donc construit en france pour le
compte d'un armateur norvégien
le voici
voici à l'eau dans champs elysées ce
soir un invité que l'on revoit avec
plaisir depuis plusieurs mois c'est dick
rivers qui fait un retour formidable
avec son dernier disque qui avec son
premier livre intitulé hamburger pan
bagnat et rock'n'roll du coup l'ancien
patron des chats sauvages redécouvre sa
passion de toujours
les belles américaines il vient
d'épouser la dernière jean jacques
dufour yves dreux étaient là pour le
voyage de noces
depuis toujours pour dick rivers
l'amérique c'est le pérou l'amérique et
surtout les belles américaines comme
cette cadillac de ville qu'il vient
d'apporter de los angeles ville où son
fils étudie le cinéma
à
nick rivers un taureau ascendant elvis
dans votre livre hamburgers pain bagnat
rock'n'roll avec ses terrasses vite pour
vous la liberté la réussite c'était ça
regardez le monde au volant d'une énorme
bagnols et je ne comprenais vraiment pas
pourquoi mon père n'avait qu'une dit
nathan à comprenait pas pourquoi mon
père ne portait pas non plus de blue
jeans
pourquoi il avait une dynamique avec des
super voitures américaines partout je
sais pas pour moi c'était un signe de
réussite c'était le rêve américain
oh
la leaf une portée de chats sauvages lui
a permis de troquer son vélo contre une
américaine sans transition aujourd'hui à
41 ans il poursuit son rêve américain au
volant d'une voiture véritable symbole
pour cet amoureux d'alice le king au
pays d'espérer rips
pas mignonne une allusion qui ne
concerne pas mon commentaire mais son
dernier tube choffat mignonne
on sait qu'une poussière
ce monde
dick un niçois qui balance entre
hambourg gher et pan bagnat cet accord
pour vous la reille
mais je sors pas d'en parler avec elle
très peu je fais de la route avec ma
qualiac non pas riches comme tous les
français j'ai ma petite aire 5/4 dick
rivers achète aussi français
je ne vais pas contre la france qui est
un très beau pays aussi déjà l'amérique
il ya le ciel est beaucoup plus grand
tout est beaucoup plus anecdotes tout
c'est à diac dit que les surnomme
christine parce qu'elles sont
capricieuses sûrement un souvenir
personnel
et si les jaunes elle
il en
leurs corps en formation l'espère ils se
sentent des côtes de porc version
américaine pour leur part les tiercés
maintenant avec les tiers c'est du week
end à bord les rapports et les résultats
d'aujourd'hui 6 15 8 combinaison
gagnante rapport dans l'ordre pour 100
francs 15 1720 de francs et 50 centimes
et puis rapport dans un ordre différent
pour la même combinaison est toujours
pour 5 francs 2007 180 francs 0 0
j'espère que vous avez bien noté que
vous avez gagné car demain à notre
tiercé secours à mai à août
pire elle exactement il va être très
passionnant ce tiercé demain après midi
à auteuil il s'agit en effet du prix
fleuret une course à handicap doté de
200 mille francs et pointue voilà mais
son intérêt vient surtout du fait
qu'elle s'adresse à un lot de 18 chevaux
âgés de 4 ans et que ces jeunes sauteurs
aborderont pour la première fois une
longue distance 4100 mètres en sautant
les obstacles du steeplechase un
parcours intérieur comme par exemple la
rue vers les 8 à rivière des tribunes on
regrette un parcours terriblement
difficile pour des chevaux encore
inexpérimenté bref c'est pas gagné
d'avancé surtout dans un terrain aussi
lourd que celui d'auteuil en ce moment
de plus certains candidats sont
fortement pénalisées ou trois puisqu'il
s'agit une course à handicap donc on
peut s'attendre à pas mal de surprises
la course est donc très ouverte seuls
les shows les plus résistants les mieux
préparés puisque les plus doués sur les
gros obstacles pourront participer à la
lutte finale
et ce n'est pas un pronostic très très
facile à faire mais je vous livre tout
de même la sélection des chevaux que je
préfère avec en tête paganelli le numéro
5 royal flip le numéro 2 b ou pour le
numéro 10 oriane salses leucate rocard
20 le numéro 6 bruno jean le numéro 16
ans 8-10 tonique le 12 et bigorre ce
numéro 15 alors notez bien leur numéro 5
de nice 4 6 16 12 et 15
la météo maintenant avec laurent
boussier heureusement laurent que le
soleil a peu brillé dans la soirée il
n'aurait pas hésité il ya eu un petit
peu plus de nuages que prévu ce lundi
pour demain j'aurais aimé vous annoncer
que le temps avait laissé son manteau de
froid de vent et de pluie mais
malheureusement il n'en est rien parce
que demain ça continue regardez-la
l'image satellite fait cet après-midi
par meteosat il y avait beaucoup de
nuages sur la france alors cela on en
parle plus on en parle encore quelques
instants ils vont s'en aller vers
l'europe de l'est
et puis il y en avait sur l'espagne et
c'est cela ce qui était aujourd'hui sur
l'espagne qui vont demain revenir sur la
france ce sont des vents ce sont des
nuages qui arrivent des masses d'air
chaudes des vents doux sera un temps
agréable mais plus regarder la carte du
temps prévu pour demain on retrouve de
l'est de l'aquitaine et des pyrénées
jusqu'au massif central au nord et au
nord-est un ciel couvert avec des
averses et parfois même des orages et
orage assez violent sur le massif
central et sur les pyrénées sur la côte
d'azur et sur les bords de la
méditerranée du beau temps ensoleillé
pas de problème tout comme sur la
bretagne sur la normandie sur les pays
de la loire est presque sûr le jusqu'à
la picardie il fera beau et les
éclaircies seront de plus en plus belle
dans l'après midi les températures sont
douces ce sont des gens qui viennent du
sud des masses d'air feeling du sud donc
des températures assez douces de 11 à 14
degrés sur la moitié nord 13 degrés à
paris et de 12,4 14 degrés dans le
centre jusqu'à 17
près de la méditerranée avec même 19°
ajaccio puis 15 degrés à bâle pourrait
ajouter une chose c'est que il y à des
risques d'avalanche et oui nous sommes
en mode et rim il ya quand même des
risques que l'avalanche parce que les
neiges qui sont de la neige qui est
tombée depuis quelques jours sur le sud
des alpes entraîne des risques que
l'avalanche important voilà on passe
maintenant à notre agenda demain sera le
mal le dimanche 5 avril le soleil se
lèvera à 7h23 se couchera à 20h25 trois
minutes de soleil en plus ils nous
fêterons les irène et demain ne seront
plus vieux d'un jour que vous l'avez dit
très justement il y en a ce temps
laurent cela dit d'ici ce soir à un
prochain rendez vous c'est avec hervé
claude ce sera aux environs de minuit 5
et puis demain des amateurs nous
retrouverons pour un nouveau journal
bonsoir très bonne soirée avec
maintenant champs elysées c'est juste
après la réclame